[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
confrontation la confrontation avec soi
même
j'imagine que tous autant que vous êtes
moi y compris vous avez des rêves des
objectifs des choses que vous avez envie
de réaliser
oui ou non donc on a envie de faire ces
choses mais je vais vous poser une
question qu'est ce qui vous en empêche
en fait la réponse c'est vous mêmes vous
empêchez vous même de réaliser les
choses que vous voyez faire est assez de
ça dont je vais parler aujourd'hui
comment devenir une personne qui arrive
à prendre les bonnes décisions à se
confronter à soi même à prendre les
bonnes décisions et à s'y mettre
tout simplement parce que c'est la chose
la plus difficile je ne sais pas si vous
êtes comme moi mais je suis du genre à
attendre le 30 du mois pour payer mon
loyer
je suis du genre à attendre la dernière
minute je leur en faire les choses à la
fin parce que j'y suis obligé
et c'est vraiment dommage parce que
réfléchissez un peu imaginer ce que
serait votre vie imaginez un seul
instant ce que serait votre vie si vous
pouviez faire les choses que vous rêvez
d'accomplir rien à qui pourrai courir le
marathon il y en a qui pourrait se
lancer dans un tour du monde y en a qui
pourraient monter leur boîte n'a qui
pourrait construire des cabanes à
oiseaux
peu importe quels sont vos objectifs que
ce soit des objectifs de carrière ou des
objectifs perso l'enjeu il est sur vous
on entend souvent parler dans ma
discipline si je peux appeler cela une
discipline qu'est le développement
personnel
on entend souvent parler de potentiel il
faut atteindre votre potentiel
il faut développer votre potentiel
chacun a un potentiel non c'est pas il
ya des gens qui n'ont pas de potentiel
alors été séparés chose qui vous limite
votre potentiel il ya des gens qui sont
bons pour des trucs et des gens qui sont
bons pour d'autres trucs
tout le monde peut pas être einstein
tout le monde peut pas être un sportif
de haut niveau mais pour moi la
problématique elle se situe pas ici la
problématique
la problématique qui fait que vous allez
pouvoir atteindre votre objectif c'est
tout simplement le fait de pouvoir se
mettre au travail et si vous observez un
petit peu les gens qui ont du succès
parce que c'est ça qui me passionne les
gens que j'observe ce sont les gens qui
ont du succès comment ils construisent
leur carrière comment il arrive à
atteindre leur succès bien il ya une
chose qui est très importante qui met
ces personnes là à part de tous les
autres une chose très importante c'est
que
personnes qui ont du succès sont les
personnes qui exécutent les personnes
qui ont du succès sont les personnes qui
exécute notez bien cette phrase les
personnes qui ont du succès sur les
personnes qui exécute et comment je vais
mettre à exécuter et bien en prenant les
bonnes décisions
d'accord notre cerveau c'est vraiment la
chose la plus puissante de la nature
house avec un adulte
ça prend en moyenne 35 mille décisions
par jour 35 mille décisions par jour
il ya tout là dedans lever la lune est
pas levé la lune elfes et des choses
comme ça mais 35 mille décisions par
jour
et pourtant la prise de décisions ça
reste quelque chose de très complexe il
ya des études qui ont été faites sur le
sujet il ya plein de il ya différentes
parties de notre cerveau qui sont
activés comme ça quand on prend une
décision
un cortex orbitofrontal le cingulaire
antérieur le cortex pariétal thalamus au
noyau caudé bonjour assure j'ai juste
appris sa part juste appris ça par coeur
avant pour faire le show mais pas besoin
d'avoir fait huit ans d'études je vous
rassure pour comprendre la prise de
décision et essayer de prendre les
bonnes décisions
voilà comment je vois les choses moi
quand on prend une décision il ya
différents facteurs qui entrent en
compte
le premier facteur c'est le risque le
danger qu'est ce qui va m'arriver si je
prends cette décision quel est le risque
si je vais parler par exemple à cet
homme qui me regardent depuis cinq
minutes
quel est le risque ou alors quel est le
risque si je ne prends pas ses décisions
quel est le risque si je n'en vois pas
ma déclaration de revenus par exemple
donc ça c'est le premier de la première
chose le risque la deuxième chose c'est
la récompense à l'être humain fonctionne
sur un système de récompense finalement
c'est assez simple un plaisir des
plaisirs récompense punition troisième
chose qui va rentrer en ligne de compte
quand on prend une décision c'est à quel
moment je vais obtenir cette récompense
est ce que je veux l'obtenir tout de
suite ou est-ce que je vais l'obtenir
dans dix ans c'est pas la même chose
il ya ensuite quel est l'effort que je
vais devoir accomplir pour obtenir cette
récompense
d'accord quel est l'effort cérébrale
pendant que vous lisez un livre c'est un
effort cérébrale ça va vous faire
plaisir mais en même temps il faut s'y
mettre et ça peut être aussi l'effort
physique d'accord donc quel est le quel
sont enfin combien ça va vous coûter en
termes de calories combien je vais
brûler de calories pour obtenir cette
récompense est enfin si
c'est une décision que vous avez à
prendre justement ça vous concerne si
vous avez envie d'améliorer vos vies si
vous avez envie de devenir une meilleure
personne que vous voulez apprendre de
nouvelles choses et que vous faites ça
sur votre temps libre
et bien quand vous allez devoir prendre
une décision il va y avoir toutes les
alternatives qui vont se présenter à
vous d'accord vous pouvez faire vous
pouvez lire un livre ou alors vous
pouvez sortir votre smartphone est allé
regarder des vidéos de chats sur
internet et vous voyez que dans ces deux
situations et bien le l'effort que sa
demande n'est pas le même et la
récompense en ce qui concerne les chabat
ça arrive beaucoup plus vite d'accord et
donc notre cerveau il arbitre en
permanence comme ça entre différentes
choses qu'il a à faire et ce que je vais
utiliser mon smartphone est ce que je
perdais des vidéos de chats sur internet
est-ce que je vais jouer à fifa est ce
que je vais faire mes révisions est ce
que je vais jouer à fifa est ce que je
veux faire l'amour avec ma partenaire
ça va vraiment jusque là ça va voir je
travaille si vous voulez avec des gens
qui sont en couple également qu'ils
veulent améliorer leur vie de couple et
qui ont cette problématique c'est un
truc que j'entends parfois ouais j'ai
j'ai pas envie de faire l'amour avec mon
partenaire avec ma partenaire et les
gens sur cette simple décision qui
pourtant ça paraît quand même évident
que c'est quelque chose qui est bon pour
un couple c'est quelque chose qui va
rapprocher les deux individus
eh bien ils ont quand même du mal à
arbitrer ils vont choisir d'aller
regarder leur compte instagram ou alors
de regarder la télévision
parfois ils vont faire les deux en même
temps et c'est vraiment quelque chose de
crucial
et pour vous inviter à prendre vos
décisions différemment ce que je veux
que vous fassiez c'est que vous ajoutiez
une variable on va ajouter une variable
dans cette dans cet arbitrage dans cette
prise de décision et la variable que
j'ai envie que vous ajoutiez c'est celle
de l'objectif quelle est la personne que
je veux devenir comment je me vois qu
est ce que je veux accomplir
et quand vous prenez vos décisions vous
allez vous poser la question suivante
ça va vous prendre une demi seconde
supplémentaire
est ce que cette décision me rapproche
de mon objectif ou m'éloigne de mon
objectif et vous allez voir que ça va
vraiment changer la donne pour vous
ainsi par exemple si je reprends
l'exemple du couple je sais pas si vous
voyez si vous êtes en couple vous êtes
amoureux et que vous voyez dans dix ans
avec la même personne
formez un couple uni complice avec vous
avec votre partenaire bien effectivement
prendre ça en compte au moment où vous
prenez votre décision passé quelque
chose qui va vous faire basculer du bon
côté et ça les prises de décision c'est
quelque chose que vous rencontrez aussi
quand vous allez vous mettre au travail
j'ai des étudiants en face à moi donc
j'imagine que vous avez cet enjeu des
révisions vous savez que si vous révisez
bien un exam vous allez avoir une bonne
note et vous savez que si vous avez une
bonne note
vous risquez de d'améliorer vos chances
dans votre carrière professionnelle
donc la prise de décision elle est
vraiment critique à ce moment là moi je
suis entrepreneur et il ya plein de gens
qui me disent ouais il ya un
entrepreneur tu as trop de chance ton
métier c'est ta passion la nasa doit
être facile de toute façon toi tu as la
motivation je vous arrête tout de suite
parce que la motivation c'est pas
quelque chose de magique
c'est quelque chose qui vous aide à
démarrer c'est quelque chose qui vous
aide à vous mettre en marche mais la
motivation c'est pas une chose sur
laquelle on peut compter
quand le succès vous allez l'atteindre
au bout d'un an deux ans trois ans
quatre ans ok je sors que parmi vous il
ya plein de personnes qui vont démarrer
quelque chose vous avez une motivation
très très forte
puis ensuite quelques jours plus tard à
cette motivation elle s'est
miraculeusement évaporés dans la nature
d'accord donc on va pas se fier sur la
motivation est ce que je voudrais faire
aujourd'hui dans ce talk c'est de vous
donner différents conseils que
j'applique à moi même et que mes clients
applique également et qui fonctionne
pour moi et si ça fonctionne pour moi il
ya une chance que ça fonctionne pour
vous comment je vais piégé mon cerveau
comment je vais à quai pour me forcer à
prendre les bonnes décisions qu'on l'a
vu déjà il faut regarder la prise de
décisions différemment et avoir un
objectif si vous n'avez pas d'objectif
trouver un objectif c'est un travail que
vous devez faire sur vous même quand on
ne sait pas pourquoi on fait une chose
est très difficile de faire cette chose
on a beaucoup de mal à y trouver du
plaisir à trouver effectivement de la
motivation
maintenant la première chose première
premier conseil que je vais vous donner
un peu plus pratique et ça ça porte sur
les situations
immédiate vraiment dans la vie de tous
les jours situation immédiate par
exemple vous arrivez dans un train il ya
des gens autour de vous vous avez envie
d'être une personne plus sociable et
vous avez envie de briser la glace et de
discuter avec ces personnes
d'accord ou alors par exemple vous allez
un forum de l'emploi vous avez une
réunion pour votre travail et vous savez
que si vous allez parler à ces gens que
vous ne connaissez pas bien ça risque
d'avoir un impact positif sur votre
carrière
et bien ce que vous allez faire à ce
moment-là c'est que vous allez dépasser
votre cerveau vous allez chercher à
contourner la prise de décision d'accord
vous allez chercher à aller plus vite
que lui
et ça c'est vraiment quelque chose de
puissant parce que moi j'ai travaillé au
début de ma carrière avec des hommes
pour les aider à faire des rencontres
donc à les aborder des filles et le
stress monte à partir du moment où on se
retrouve dans cette prise de décision
ok je le fais je le fais pas vous allez
me dire c'est pareil sur un plongeoir je
saute je saute pas bien plus vous allez
attendre plus le stress va monter donc
ce que vous allez chercher à faire c'est
à dépasser votre cerveau et à agir avant
même d'avoir à prendre la décision en
pilote automatique si je puis dire et
dans les situations sociales que je
viens d'évoquer
et bien vous allez arriver et vous avez
tout simplement saluer les personnes
dites leur bonjour le plus gros du
travail va être fait une fois que vous
avez dit bonjour à une personne cette
personne a l'autorisation de vous parler
vous avez l'autolyse l'autorisation de
lui parler à nouveau et votre niveau de
stress
il va être divisé par dix deuxième
conseil que je vais vous donner c'est
totalement différent du premier
c'est l'anticipation au lieu de prendre
ma décision
maintenant je vais prendre ma décision
des heures et des heures et des heures
avant en fait j'ai pas envie d'arriver
sur cette situation d'arbitrage dans
l'immédiat en demandant à mon cerveau de
décider ce qu'ils préfèrent faire ce que
je vais faire c'est que je vais
anticipées je vous donne un exemple pour
ça imaginez par exemple que je vous dise
demain vous allez vous lever à 5 heures
du matin et vous allez allez courir une
heure et bien si je vous le dis
maintenant il y en a que ça gêne y en a
clairement ils sont pas prêts pour ça
mais si je vous le dis maintenant vous
avez le temps d'anticiper sa vous avez
le temps de vous y faire vous avez le
temps de deux vous visualisez en train
d'aller courir vous avez le temps de
vous préparer
et vous allez pouvoir vous blindés c'est
quelque chose qui va vous permettre de
vous armer
face à cette prise de décision alors que
si demain matin je vais frapper chez
vous à 5h du matin je pense qu'il ya pas
mal d'entre vous qui vont envoyer chier
donc c'est ça c'est l'anticipation
achetez vous un agenda qui parmi vous
qui parmi vous a un agenda papier même
pas un dixième de la salle achetez vous
un agenda papier quelque chose vous
allez pouvoir pouvoir sur la même page
parce que l'agenda dans le téléphone
faut pas se leurrer il faut rentrer à
l'intérieur ce n'est pas visible moi je
vous demande d'avoir quelque chose de
visible quelque chose que vous pouvez
regarder ça va vous aider à anticiper
votre lendemain une chose que je fais
personnellement c'est que j'utilise le
dernier moment de la journée
pour visualiser la journée prochaine et
pour me préparer à fournir les efforts
que je sais que je dois faire parce que
c'est en concordance avec mes objectifs
est un exemple que j'adore c'est le
nageur michael phelps vous connaissez
tous michael phelps le nageur grand
champion son coach baumann
il a travaillé avec lui donc il a repéré
ce petit garçon qu'elle a grand or ce
qu'avait des grands bryce est dit allah
lui la halle physique pour être un
champion mais si vous regardez les
jaunes natation tout le monde a le
physique pour être un champion
alors ça suffit pas et lui s'est dit il
faut travailler sur son mental et il
peut pas en tant que coach est présent
dans tous les moments de sa vie et on
sait très bien qu'il ya plein de choses
qui peuvent influencer le succès un des
mauvaises fréquentations ça peut être
plein de choses sur lesquelles le coach
n'a aucun impact et ce qui lui a dit
tout simplement la chose sur laquelle il
a travaillé c'est l'anticipation il lui
a demandé chaque soir avant de se
coucher de se passer la cassette
alors c'est une cassette fictive bien
sûr il va pas donner une vhs qui devait
se passer
et cette cassette qu'est ce qu'il ya
dedans et bien en fait il lui a demandé
de se voir en train de courir la course
de nager plus tôt la course parfaite il
doit se voir au ralenti il doit voir
chacun de ses mouvements il doit
vraiment voir voir ça de manière très
précise et ça va même plus loin il doit
se voir gagner touché le mur en premier
se voir sortir la tête de l'eau avec les
gouttes qui ruisselle sur le visage et
laisser exploser sa joie quand il voit
qu'il a gagné la course oui
l'anticipation va aller jusqu'au plaisir
que vous allez
vivre quand vous allez atteindre votre
objectif vous quand vous allez réussir à
faire cette tâche que vous n'avez pas
envie de faire en troisième conseil
c'est l'obligation qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on a un quand on a le cerveau qui
patine qui n'arrivent pas à arbitrer
et bien la réponse est très simple on va
se munir d'un deuxième cerveau tout
simplement qui ne va pas souffrir du
même bug
donc vous allez vous entourer de
quelqu'un d'autre entourez-vous des gens
qui ont envie de réussir autant que vous
allez chercher ces personnes-là effet
devant vos alliés ça peut être vos
partenaires de business ça peut être des
gens dans votre entourage ça peut être
votre famille ça peut être votre
partenaire amoureux
on a toujours cette image du succès
comme quelque chose voilà la traversée
solitaire le mec qui a écrit son livre
tout seul pendant sept ans il a sorti
son livre ou alors le sportif qui s'est
entraîné tout seul pendant des années
enfin il est champion
mais en réalité ça c'est un fantasme si
vous étudiez un peu les entrepreneurs
vous allez voir que c'est très très rare
qui est une seule personne qui soit
associé à son propre succès bien souvent
il ya quelqu'un visibles ou invisibles
ça peut être une personne qui est dans
l'ombre mais qui va aider cette personne
si je prends le cas de michael fait je
les dis il ya son coach baumann voulons
vous enlevez le coach vous enlevez
peut-être le champion pour nous français
mais beaucoup plus connus il ya laure
manaudou et merci philippe lucas
philippe lucas si vous retirez philippe
lucas il ya plus de laure manaudou c'est
pareil michael jackson c'est son père
qui était derrière lui alors même si ses
méthodes étaient un petit peu
controversé et oui il ya toujours des
gens qui sont derrière
quand vous allez buggé vous allez avoir
besoin d'une personne qui va vous
pousser en avant donc vous devez trouver
quelqu'un qui est con qui est compatible
avec vous qui ne va pas à voir s'ils
voulaient les mêmes défauts vous êtes
perfectionniste trouver quelqu'un qui va
vous aider à balancer votre travail en
vous disant voilà c'est un parfait on y
va quand même si vous êtes flemmards
vous devez trouver quelqu'un qui est
foot boulot vous devez comme ça vous
associer avec une personne qui va vous
obliger à prendre les bonnes décisions
et à vous
être mon quatrième conseil c'est de se
faire violence dans la vie quand on est
dans un bras de fer à un moment donné si
on veut gagner il faut utiliser un peu
de violence
et ça c'est quelque chose que
personnellement j'utilise et ça fait ça
me fait bizarre d'expliquer ce conseil
parce que ça a l'air un peu tordu comme
ça mais je donne un exemple j'avais
arrêté de filmer pendant une longue
période et je voulais me remettre et je
savais que c'était la bonne chose à
faire et j'ai été pris comme ça dans cet
arbitrage n'arrivais pas à me décider
j'avais ma caméra dans la main je savais
qu'il fallait que je démarre que ça
allait être pourri au début et bien pour
me faire basculer du bon côté j'ai dû
utiliser la violence
un peu comme les sportifs ça y est les
tennismen quand il frappe dans la balle
ils vont crier en même temps ça leur
permet de décupler leurs forces ça leur
permet psychologiquement de concentrer
toutes leurs forces au même endroit mais
vous allez faire la même chose vous
allez faire preuve de violence ça peut
être 2e de crier comme ça de pouce à qui
ça va être là qu'ils vont vouloir se
taper leurs vous tapez pas le visage
mais faire usage d'un tout petit peu de
violence de laisser exploser sa à ce
moment là je vous garantis que si vous
êtes pris au milieu du bras de fer bien
c'est quelque chose qui va vous aider à
passer du bon côté
en tout cas c'est une chose qui marche
pour moi et si vous voulez cultiver sa
et bien vous devez vous à prendre avec
vous même à gagner un maximum de bras de
fer
c'est ce qui va vous apprendre la
discipline dites-vous non non je vais
pas le starbucks me manger cet énorme
frappuccino non je vais pas fumé cette
cigarette
apprenez à vous dire non plus vous allez
être capable de vous discipliner de vous
dire non un maximum de fois dans la
journée
bien sûr récompensé vous à un moment
donné mais plus vous allez être capable
de gagner ses bras de fer est bien plus
quand la situation va se présenter vous
allez avoir de voir frapper fort
usé de violence à bien vous allez avoir
beaucoup plus de facilité enfin dernier
conseil dernier conseil pour hacker
votre cerveau et c'est un conseil qui
marche pour moi également en fait je
vais utiliser je vais utiliser selon les
situations l'un ou l'autre des conseils
que je vous ai donné mais le dernier
conseil c'est de vous piéger
d'accord vous allez vous tant dans la
piège si par exemple je sais que je dois
écrire un article pour mon travail
régulièrement j'écris des articles et je
sais que ça va me demander trois heures
c'est long trois heures et quand je
quand je vois justement cette énergie
que ça va me demander ce temps que ça va
me demander ma récompense qui va arriver
seulement à la fin de la journée bien
j'ai pas envie de bien
être un homme comme la plupart d'entre
vous quand il s'agit de réviser vous
savez que vous allez passer des heures
et des heures vous n'avez pas envie de
vous y mettre
ce que je fais je piège mon cerveau au
lieu de me dire mec tu vas écrire un
article ce que je me dis c'est que je
vais simplement prendre cinq minutes
pour rédiger la structure de l'article
qu'elle est différents paragraphes et
les différentes idées qui va y avoir à
l'intérieur et en fait le fait de
minimiser l'effort que je vais devoir
produire bien ça me permet de me mettre
beaucoup plus simplement je peux me
mettre c'est pas grave c'est pour cinq
minutes après je vais pouvoir aller
faire autre chose mais en réalité une
fois que j'y suis bien justement j'ai
tendance à 5 minutes à se transforme en
un quart d'heure vingt minutes une heure
puisque c'est une tâche
en fait la grosse difficulté c'est
vraiment de s'y coller et une fois que
vous êtes partis et bien vous allez
avoir tendance à fournir plus de travail
que ce que vous vous êtes dit au début
voilà les conseils que je vous donne qui
fonctionne pour bras qui fonctionne pour
mes clients qui vont je l'espère vous
aider à prendre les meilleures décisions
et à vous rapprocher de vos objectifs
c'est vraiment le fait de se confronter
à soi-même pour progresser pour moi
c'est vraiment un travail sur le long
terme c'est un travail sur soi dans
lequel on est confronté à ces peurs on
est confronté à ces faiblesses on est
confronté à sa part s on est confronté à
son entourage en est confronté à plein
de choses on est confronté au schéma
qu'on a suivi depuis qu'on est enfant
est pour moi la confrontation le fait
d'analyser de comprendre comment on
fonctionne d'essayer de conceptualiser
ça pour mieux comprendre et bien pour
moi c'est déjà la moitié du travail de
fait vers l'amélioration
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire aujourd'hui merci de l'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]